being nice just makes life so much
easier
a Fiat x19 that had a hole in the
floorboard I mean you can tell I was
living the high life I tell my kids that
hey if they want something they're gonna
have to earn it
yeah and be if they don't work hard
enough to earn it I'm gonna sell them
off as medical experiments wanna soar
get a mentor
[Music]
so today let's learn from one of the
best Mark Cuban and some of his best
life-changing advice mentor me mark okay
let's kick it off with rule number one
be nice nice is way undervalued you know
particularly in this day and age you
know if you turn on the news everything
seems like it's gonna get blown up right
being nice just makes life so much
easier and look I learned the hard way I
had to have my partner Todd came to me
one day and he goes I like to curse he
goes I don't care about cursing but you
curse too much not everybody is as
accepting as cursing as you are calm the
[ __ ] down
and I took at the heart not so much the
cursing part but but I just it became
apparent to me that the nicer I got the
more effective people around me got the
more productive they got the more sales
we had I was undervaluing nice you know
I started my my first company after I
got fired from a job and I was 24 just
turned 24 my first real company if you
will and I was always go go go go go all
consumed right live it eat it sleep it
breathe it and I knew people couldn't
keep up or work as hard as many hours as
me but I wanted them to and we were
successful and we didn't have much
turnover but I could have done a better
job if I were nicer and broadcast calm I
got a little bit nicer right
that's things but then once I got to the
Mavs and
and some of these other companies and
Todd reminded me you know and and really
told me you know just nice nice works
and so when you find yourself going to
work when you're finding yourself
dealing with customers when you're
finding yourself making decisions we all
get that ah jatai right that feeling in
her stomach that tenseness that stress
at various points at times that we all
have to go through but sometimes you
just need to calm the down right take a
deep breath and be nice because you'll
find out that people will do much more
but if you reduce the stress to people
and you're nice you're gonna have such a
huge advantage no matter what your
technology is no matter how it compares
even if it's a download for an app
people will still have to deal with you
your culture will come through being
nice being being supportive reducing
stress that all comes through even in an
app rule number two
take risks a Fiat x19 that had a hole in
the floorboard I mean you could tell I
was living the high life right I mean
and I was putting in oil every 60 miles
and you know working as a bartender at
night what did I have to lose you know
and so it wasn't like haha man you know
this is I can lose all this and yeah and
so it was just like you just go for it
now later on after I had some success
and we got back and we started an audio
net which turned into broadcast comm
that the math was different the
equations you know the calculus was
different it was like okay I'm investing
a lot of my saved money into this whole
idea of net casting right or internet
broadcasting in early 1995 when people
didn't even know what the internet was
that was all risk because I literally
was putting everything that I had on the
line for something people just laughed
at me and said wait audio over the
Internet you know you can turn on the
radio you know you know you can turn on
the TV yeah but you don't get it no
that's just dumb all right you know and
and so being able to overcome all that
resistance because remember back then
hey you had to have a PC B you had to
know what a modem was and install it C
you had to know what the internet was
and then
to download a tcp/ip client that worked
over a modem and then connected to a
browser that you probably didn't even
know what it was or how to download it
and we had to take it on faith that all
this was going to grow rule number three
outwork everyone most people do a lot of
talking and most people don't put in the
effort there's nothing you can't
accomplish in life with the right amount
of work the challenge is you know are
you willing to do the work and the
reality is most people aren't but that's
the opportunity right is I mean it's
like people you know at school most
people are lazy right they they just
they barely get through it and and so
that creates opportunity I tell my kids
that a if they want something they're
gonna have to earn it
yeah and B if they don't work hard
enough to earn it I'm gonna sell them
off as medical experiments that's the
line in our house you need money okay
we'll set you off as a medical
experiment we can get you money that way
give blood dad I'm seven I don't care
also if you want to have more confidence
and self-love check on my 254 series
they're free the link to join are in the
description below I've always been
passionate some people say you know it's
a it's more OCD than anything else
I always did everything back pass half
words you know I like to challenge
myself those back-to-back experiences
confirmed what I already knew that I was
a yes employee and then I better start
my own rule number four be brutally
honest with yourself one of the big
things that all startups do is they lie
to themselves over and over and over
minds faster minds cheaper mine's better
minds this Minds that no it's not and
the reason it's not is because whoever
it is you're competing with it's not
like they're ignoring you it's not like
oh my goodness this guy just started on
Shopify in the startup competition he's
doing a million dollars this year what
was me I might as well close up the
doors what are they doing I'm gonna copy
what they're doing and now you've got to
stay ahead and so you know you've got to
be very careful as an entrepreneur to
be brutally honest with yourself and
those are some of the things that you'll
hear from me as a mentor that you know
know what you know know what you don't
know but you've got to know your
business better than anybody rule number
five be prepared to win there's part of
you that either wants to create a
business or you're off obviously already
have created a business the hardest part
is taking that first step right there's
always that line like I was talking
about earlier that you have to take a
step pass but the thing people always
say well you know you're not afraid to
start a business why aren't you it's
terrifying or you know you I just it
scares me to do it and my my attitude
has always been if you're prepared it's
not a risk right Bobby Knight who was
the coach at Indiana University used to
say everybody's got the will to win but
it's only those with the will to prepare
that do win and the same applies to
business we've all seen her friends go
out there and just wing it
you know it's my passion we're all
passionate about something I'm
passionate about basketball doesn't make
me an NBA player right it's not just
about passion it's not just about saying
I'm doing it it's not even about
incorporating it's not about the idea
it's about are you prepared and are you
willing to do the work and rule number
six the last one before a very special
bonus clip is try out different things
you just have to try different things
and even even if 99% of them fail you
only have to be right one time you don't
have to figure it all out in advance you
can be wrong you could pick the wrong
career you can pick the wrong job you
can pick the wrong spouse you can pick
the wrong whatever but you get it right
one time you're set but if you don't try
and if you don't go out there and try
all those different things you'll never
get that one time and so it's not a
question of okay how much different
stuff do I do or how many different
things should you try try them all try
them all until you find the one you like
and then it's like it gets really easy
because even when it's up you're on a
mission you're loving what you do you
know and then then it gets easy and so
that's just the approach I've always
tried to instill in people who work for
me and myself
I have a special bonus tip from mark on
how to always be a student that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one where do you need to
be more brutally honest with yourself
number two what's the risk that you need
to take this week and number three how
can you just be nice to somebody today I
focus on things that are AI driven
artificial intelligence driven whether
it's machine learning deep learning
learning neural networks medical
applications but within ai ai is a buzz
word that everybody's using right now
you know every in and to that point you
know we as all guys we go back and it's
like 1995 we talked about the internet
and I would say to people back in 1995
look if you don't understand the
internet you're not gonna be able to do
business and now that's just blocking
attack lane that seems obvious back then
it wasn't right I could even take you
further back to my first company you
know what we did was a company called
micro solutions and we did local area
networks on wide area networks and I
used to walk into companies and say
you're gonna have to hook these pcs
together at some point that'll make you
more productive more effective you know
give you a competitive advantage and
people are like now I just carry this
floppy from this PC to that PC
yeah okay but today we're at the same
type of inflection point with artificial
intelligence you don't have to be an
expert and be able to put together your
own neural network you know you don't
have to know what weights and biases are
but but you have to have more than just
a cursory understanding just like you
have to know the difference between you
know different types of websites and you
have to understand ecommerce if you're
in the e-commerce you have to have a
cursory understanding of how apps work
you're gonna have to have at least if
not more cursory understanding of
artificial intelligence because it will
change everything we do and if the
internet was 10x in terms of change to
business artificial intelligence will be
100x or more if you go to my house right
next to my bed
a book machine-learning for dummies to
go into my bathroom there's deep neural
networks for dummies right if you go
there's a something for dummies in every
room of my house you know they could go
to ways I know but I'm just telling you
put the time I mean I've taken you know
I can't even tell you how many hours now
I spend every week if not daily working
like I'll go into Amazon AWS and go
through their machine learning tutorials
don't think to yourself I'm not
technical enough or I'm not gonna get
this or I don't get into this or it's
too much try it get as far as you can
because it's like doing a basic website
and a little bit of HTML just having
done that you feel smarter and you feel
a little bit more confident about this
you know I don't want to be an alarmist
but I'm trying to scare the hell out of
you
because it's important
if you want to know Mark Cuban's
investing strategies check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
I really don't have any one thing I try
to to be objective about each company
but I guess I look for something that's
differentiated